hey everyone it's Mike Balto's from
order flows and welcome to today's
presentation on how to spot market
exhaustion that leads to big market
moves now in this presentation I'm going
to discuss two different forms of order
flow analysis which when you separately
are powerful on their own but one
combined can give you some beautiful
powerful trading opportunities and they
are market imbalances and market
exhaustion but before I begin you know I
just want to introduce myself for those
that are new to me my name is Michael
Walters I've been in the futures
industry since the early 90s I started
on the CMA floor as a runner with Dean
Witter eventually I left the trading
floor to go trade upstairs on the off
the floor trading that's when Globex was
starting up after that I left there for
EDF man for a few years EDF man is a big
English commodity trading firm then I
joined Commerce Bank for three years I
was a license your ex trader based in
Chicago trading Bulls Bob well schatz
Dax Euro stocks and you know the other
smaller indices like the banks and tech
into indices then I joined Cargill I
spent four years with Cargill as a
trading desk manager we traded every
commodity basically you can imagine in
the world then I joined JP Morgan I
spent eight years era's bikes president
of Futures Trading you know this was a
job where I said on the trading desk
rate and I didn't sit in some corner
office I'm looking at spreadsheets and
all you know I thought it would come in
at just before 6:00 in the morning and I
would leave around 5:00 in the afternoon
did this for eight years after being
tired of that you know I realized that's
not what I want to do with my life
anymore you know as I was in my 40s and
you know I left I said I can't I can't
do this because I got a family now and
you know I need to spend time with them
so I left I started trading for myself
my own account and I started writing my
book on trading order flow and in 2015 I
started order flows dot-com now what I'm
about to show you can be applied by any
trader who wants to see market
exhaustion and market imbalances most
importantly I'm gonna show you how to
see these order flow opportunities on a
normal bar or candlestick chart so you
don't need to look at a dome or volume
footprint chart you don't need level 2
data you just need a normal chart to
look at it
now before I begin I just gotta go
through a brief disclaimer you know
please realize that trading involves
risk past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results and only
please only trade with risk capital that
you can afford to lose so the first part
of my talk about is market imbalances
and market imbalances are one piece of
order flow data that can transform your
trading so let me ask you are you using
it most traders they're not your most
traders are unable to determine when
imbalances are happening right under
their nose and why are imbalances
important is because you know just like
this truck versus the Corvette the truck
wins you know it's gonna win nine times
out of ten because it's bigger right and
that's what happens when you have a
market imbalance right you have bigger
size versus smaller size you know I tell
my wife you know I said I when I buy a
car I always want a big car because you
know if I'm gonna be involved in an
accident I want to be protected I'm sure
there's protection in numbers now most
traders are unable to determine when
imbalances are happening why is because
number one they treat all traded prices
the same at number two they treat all
traders the same so what does that mean
I treat all traded price is the same
treat all traders the same well let's
break it down the first one all prices
traded are not the same you know it's
not a car as a car or a purse as a purse
right you have a Ferrari or you could
have a Volkswagen right one is going to
be better than the other for other
reasons and same thing with price you
know there could be a certain price
that's traded could be more important
than a different price just as a purse
right Louis Vuitton versus you know your
canvas handbag which is going to be more
expensive and more valuable well it's
gonna be the Louis Vuitton bag because
it's you know it's hand-stitched it's
made with leather that's gonna last
longer and I hate to say but being more
expensive sometimes you know people are
gonna take better care of it all right
so you know for fur the men can relate
to this you know I'm married yet
every time I go shopping with my wife
she wants to go to Zara
this is our pretty much every major
shopping mall across the country yet
she's got to go in I'm like why I can't
keep I was gonna go to Zara right
they're all the same well no they're not
you know this one may have something
here on sale this one may have you know
these these other clothes or whatever
okay you know I just go with it
but you know just as not all prices are
the same not every Zara outlet store
whatever you want to call it is going to
be the same now number two traitors are
different right each trader has a
different reason for entering a trade
they there are speculators or hedgers
real money accounts there's producers
there's CTAs there's hedge funds you
know there's algos and etc you know it's
probably something I haven't covered now
once you understand that there's
different types of traders and there's
different prices importance you know
being traded you got to understand that
within the different types of traders
you also have different short
classifications of traders right you
have passive traders you have aggressive
traders passive traders are willing to
wait for the market to come to them they
work bids they work offers aggressive
traders need to get into the market
right now without waiting they're gonna
buy at the market they're gonna buy the
offer or they're gonna sell the bid but
you know people sometimes they they
don't understand what that really means
well there's a difference right you have
passive fishermen and aggressive
fishermen hopefully everybody
understands what a fisherman does right
so if you're passive you know you just
want to sit on the on the rocks you know
throw your bait in the water let the
fish come to you you're passive you know
if you don't catch a fish that day
that's fine
you know you'll eat something else
aggressive trader an aggressive
fisherman rather he's gonna go out into
the water where the fish are he's gonna
throw his net to the area where the fish
are he may even throw bait in there just
to get the fish to come to him all right
so he's being aggressive in the sense
that he's going out and actively
catching the fish whereas the passive
fisherman yeah you know if I catch a
fish you know great you know if not I
had a good time I sat out here in in the
nice
you know I had a beer or two and you
know I enjoyed myself so whether he
catches the fish or not he doesn't care
the aggressive fishermen he needs to
catch a fish he needs to eat he needs to
catch a fish to sell to put food on the
table for his family so on a dome right
most people are familiar with the dome
and you have passive buyers on the bid
side they're working the bid and the
working bids below the bid passive
sellers work the offer they work offers
above the current offer right if they
don't get elected if they don't no one
trades with them yeah they're fine you
know they could live where as an
aggressive trader someone that's going
to lift the offer from the passive
seller or sell into the bid and sell
into the passive buyer so who's going to
move the market now you know think about
it what makes the market go up or down
passive traders or aggressive traders
right go back to your dome well if the
markets 5575 bid offer 256 okay that's
great it's not going to trade right for
it to trade in the market to start
moving someone has to buy at the market
or sell at the market so I want us to
lift the offer someone has to hit the
bid so now that you understand the
difference between aggressive traders
and passive traders you can understand
when there are imbalances in the market
because when an imbalance occurs all
right what you're gonna have is you're
gonna have a certain amount trading on
the offer versus the bid all right and
when it reaches a certain level a
certain percentage that's what's called
an imbalance so let's go back to our
dome all right all the bids and all the
offers sitting in the order book are
passive traders remember right there
passes because they're waiting for the
market to come to them so for trade to
occur someone has to be aggressive for a
trade to occur there must be a trader
who either sells into the bid or buys
from the offer right for the market to
move up all the offers at a price must
either be bought by aggressive buyers or
all the offers at the current offer be
pulled out of the market in a new higher
offerors present and
that traits you know for market to move
down all the bids at a price must either
be sold by aggressive sellers or the
bids pulled and a new lower bid present
so for example markets not gonna move if
no one's buying the 56s or selling the
55 and 3/4 I just gonna sit there people
are gonna try to buy it at 55 and 3/4
people don't try to sell it at 56 so for
the market to move someone has to sell
into the bid or buy the offer so markets
move up on aggressive buying
traders are buying the best offer
they're clearing it out alright then
find the next best offer well at the
same time the aggressive selling is not
enough to clear out the best bid all
right so what you're happening what's
happening right remember markets are a
two-way auction so there's people
constantly buying and selling right
people are buying the 56 is selling the
55 and 3/4 but for the market to move
the buying move up rather the buying has
got to be more than the selling all
right and if it's more than a certain
amount you're gonna call that an
imbalance so for market to move down all
the bids at a price must either be sold
by aggressive sellers or the bids pole
than a new lower bid present right the
markets that will move down on
aggressive selling traders are selling
the best bid clearing it out selling the
next best bid etc right for the market
to move down someone's gonna have to
sell the 55 and 3/4 and start selling
the 55 and a half's once those are
cleared out some can be pulled the next
bid is fifty five and a quarter someone
hits all those next bid 55 that's how a
market moves down now that's not to say
there's no counter trade you know there
might be people offering it down here as
well and you know a couple buyers come
in and buy some okay but in general what
you have is an imbalance you have more
people selling this would cause the
market to go down so on a normal
candlestick chart you only see price
movements right you don't see well who's
buying at a price level how much they're
buying you know on a dome you can see it
in real time but then it's gone you know
some of these domes nowadays are a bit
more fancy you know it'll track the
numbers that trade it but you know you
gotta be Rain Man and then sit there and
try to figure out okay well it was this
one that happened you know 30 seconds
ago what's the importance of that volume
that traded now a footprint chart right
allows you to see it in real time and
frames it in an easy-to-read format so I
could see when there are buying
imbalances in a bar I can see when there
are selling imbalances in a bar and
those will be highlighted in the volume
in a bar so those of you that are not
familiar with and order flow chart this
is what an order flows trader footprint
chart this is what it looks like right
and you can see that over time it tells
a story right you can need to see how
the bars are forming you know volumes
being traded I could see when there's
buying imbalances you know that would be
the blue numbers inside of the bar or a
red number inside the bar would be a
selling imbalance right and you can see
how it's you know it's more relaxed it's
not as stressful as say looking at a
dome where you're sitting here trying to
figure out oh my gosh what does this
mean you know it gives you a more
classical sense of what's happening in
the market more of a tape reading you
know people say well you know your tape
readers should be looking at time and
sales honestly the way time and sales
move so fast you know if you can't keep
up with it all right you need something
that puts that information into an
easy-to-read format and that is a
footprint chart all right so now that we
know what makes the market move up and
down its aggressive trading right how do
you determine if it imbalance is
occurring well you look at the ratio of
aggressive buying at the offer versus
the aggressive selling into the bid
right I had hinted at that so this is
why using a footprint chart is useful
all right because you're gonna be able
to see that volume in the bar so for
example 500 contracts traded on the
offer
meaning 500 contracts which bought by
aggressive traders versus 400 contracts
are being sold into the bid by
aggressive sellers you'd be looking at
500 versus 400 not perfectly matched but
still relatively even right but what if
what if you had 500 Lots trading on the
offer versus just 50 Lots traded on the
bid
that's 500 versus 50 that would be
considered an imbalance why it's ten to
one right when you have 500 versus 400
that's not an imbalance you know you're
pretty much even in a general sense
people say whoa 500 not 400 you know
don't get your panties in and you know
too tightly wound up you know you're
looking for excesses in the market right
500 versus 400 again still relatively
evenly matched 500 against 50 it's not
evenly matched you know for a perfect
example you'll figure out which is
balanced right one against one one
against four one against six all right
one against one you know that the one
guy on the left may weigh 150 pounds the
guy on the left on the right
you know maybe 170 pounds okay you know
there's a weight discrepancy there of
you know whatever 20 pounds you know but
still relatively evenly matched you know
but you could have won you know the guy
on the Left could weigh 150 pounds the
guy on the right could weigh 150 pounds
evenly match but then the next guy 150
pounds the next guy 150 pounds the next
guy 150 pounds right so you got four
guys against one guy you know and
obviously six against one is it's not an
evenly matched
you know definition of imbalance is lack
of balance right state of being out of
equilibrium out of proportion you know
the whole concept of market profile
deals with balance in the market and
when the markets not in balance so if
you don't think that knowing when the
markets imbalanced is not important you
know you I think you just leave an
important piece of information out of
the trading equation so in the order
flow you must decide what you consider
an imbalance between aggressive buyers
and aggressive sellers the starting
point that most people use this for two
one four hundred percent some traders
use three two one three hundred percent
other traders use ten to one you know
which is a thousand percent it's up to
you to decide what's best for you I'm
telling you right now most people use
four hundred percent four to one what
does that mean well if you're looking at
an inbound footprint chart you can see
you know what was traded on the bid what
was traded on the offer so for example
this green bar right here on the right
okay
you see 70 against 0 well 0 against 70
70 lots traded at 33 32 38 versus zero
at 30 to 37 and 3/4 0 against 70
obviously more than 4 to 1
that's a buying imbalance ok now go down
1 2 3 4 bars earlier right down here you
know sort of towards the middle you see
51 against 9
all right so 51 Lots traded on the bid
at 24 and a half versus 9 Lots traded on
the offer at 24 and 3/4 so you have you
know that's about 5 to 1 that exceeds
the ratio of 4 to 1 so you have a
selling imbalance right
you have 51 Lots traded on the bid
versus only 9 traded on the offer when
the market was bid-offer there okay now
you gonna have a lot of black numbers
because there's no imbalance that's just
your regular order flow and you can see
these bars here this this red bar in the
bottom you know towards the low 50
against 109 okay it's not imbalanced
it's it's a two-to-one ratio more or
less but it's not considered an
imbalance because I'm using 4 to 1
137 against 371 again not an imbalance
it's about 3 to 1 377 against 41 not an
imbalance for 50 against 603 not an
imbalance 625 against 175 not an
imbalance you know it's close about 3 to
1 but it's not it's not 4 to 1 you know
it again it's not a line drawn in the
stand that you have to use for the 1
again some people prefer to use 3 to 1
some people use 5 to 1 some people use 6
to 1 it's up to you to find what is the
level that you're comfortable with you
know if you have a very low threshold
you're gonna get more imbalances if you
have a very high threshold you're going
to get less imbalances so you know
trying to see it on a dome you're not
right it just happens so fast that
you're not gonna know you know you can't
sit here and do the math in your head on
how much traded you know on the bid on
the on the offer right on a bar chart
you don't even looking at the volume
that's traded in the bar so forget about
it you know a footprint
puts it in a nice easy to read form that
you can make a trading decision so now
that you can identify an imbalance in
the market how are you gonna use this
information well what you want to do
obviously is you want to highlight the
clusters of imbalances but not just
stacked imbalances but bars with
multiple imbalances in them so let me
just break that down so what is a
stacked imbalance well you can see
that's this green area in the middle of
this chart right you have a 109 again 7
10 30 against 190 11 against 151 that is
called the stacked imbalance the
imbalances are stacked one on top of the
other on top of the other now this is
what most traders look for because it
helps them to define near-term support
right if it's a stack mine and balance
or resistance when a stack selling
imbalance appears right so for example
markets going down you guys stacks on a
balanced aggressive sellers come in and
hit the bids but I clear out all the
bids there it leaves this footprint so
to speak of a stack selling a balance
and you notice what happens the market
now I've come back into that area it's
acting as resistance right it's a
selling imbalance right did you see how
the market can't really get past it gets
one tick above and it holds it holders
market sells off you know another
example we're here at the high of the
day this is Green Line stacks on the
balance comes in it appears right we hit
our high today sellers are coming out of
the woodwork start hitting all the bids
mark and start selling off market just
trades back up into that imbalance
before falling over now I've got a
market generated resistance level now
there's another form of imbalance and
very few people really talk about it
excuse me drink of water there and what
it is it's it's a multiple imbalance and
it's what that is is when you have three
or more imbalances in a bar but they're
not neatly stacked on top of each other
you know when they stack neatly on top
of each other you know at the high of
the day that's great you know that
that's just textbook charting you know
you know people are gonna post it up
online see you know order flow is the
greatest
etc you know here you got obviously
aggressive sellers coming into the
market but just because they're not
stacked on each other on top of each
other doesn't mean they're not important
right most traders are you know that's
what they're taught to look for in order
flow is this actor taught to look for
the stacked imbalance you got to look
for this red zone you know this green
zone you know all the major footprint
charts software has it but you know what
my order flows trader software does is
they also look for bars with multiple
imbalances and as you can see here you
don't see any stacks selling imbalances
instead you've seen multiple selling
imbalances in a bar so my software will
put a purple box around it around the
bar you know put the box around whether
it's a stack mine and balancer stacks
selling a balanced
you obviously have eyes you can make
that determination I never thought it
was useful to have you know also
different colors for stacked buying and
multiple binding balances multiple
selling imbalances because you know
you're you're the best computer is the
one between your your ears but you hit I
could see you know one two three selling
imbalances next bar one two three
selling imbalances a few bars later one
two three selling imbalances what's
happening we're coming up to a swing
high here aggressive selling is coming
in but it's coming in sporadically right
you know not all big traders you have
you know a big order they're just gonna
below just tell me you know my five
hundred snps right now you know they're
gonna sell a little let the market
breathe sell some more let the market
breathe you let the market breathe so it
comes back up and they sell at a better
price rather than just coming in with
you know up unity and hitting all the
bids sometimes that works for them
sometimes it doesn't you know sometimes
the market doesn't come back sometime
traders pick up on it alright here we
are you know we're at our low of the day
what's happening market starts ticking
up and then boom the aggressive buyers
appear you get this bar you got one two
three four five buying imbalances this
is a 30 second crude chart okay over
here five bars later you have a stacked
buying imbalance right and then the
market goes higher well
you're being alerted earlier with the
multiple imbalances rather than later
with the stacked imbalances and as you
can see on this previous chart you don't
even have stacks element balances so if
you're sitting here looking for stacks
Elenin balances you know you're going to
be waiting you know it's the way I would
describe it in a sense is you know these
people that use these these fancy
technical indicators you know bad
patterns don't be sending me hateful
emails little bad patterns are the you
know guard leaves are the greatest thing
ever if they work for you fantastic but
oftentimes you're just sitting around
waiting and waiting for something that
just never appears and if you're gonna
be sitting around waiting and waiting
for multiple imbalances they appear a
lot less than nice if you just sit
around waiting for stacked imbalances
they pair a lot less than multiple
imbalances and more importantly multiple
imbalances often occur ahead of step
stacked imbalances right as you can see
in this chart right here's your multiple
imbalances five bars earlier than your
stacked imbalance so while multiple
imbalances are not visually appealing as
stacked imbalance they're Justin as
important if not more important to
traders multiple imbalances and stacked
imbalances tell you the same thing
aggressive traders are presence right
the difference is on a stacked imbalance
aggressive traders are piling into the
market right now bar with multiple
imbalances tell you aggressive traders
are active but they're trading in waves
they're trying to hide what they're
doing right and you know it's let me ask
you what do you think is stronger trader
shows you his aggressiveness at once or
trader
hiding his aggressiveness you know
perfect example there was an interview
with Lance Armstrong okay yeah I know he
used peds during the Tour de France but
you know he in one of his interviews his
tone you know the the guy at ESPN you
know when he was riding up the mountain
he would pretend that you know he was
out of breath that you know he's
you know got no more strength so the
other riders would get a little bit you
know excited about that and you know try
to you know expend more energy now but
what he was doing was he was hiding his
aggressiveness now in baseball pitchers
you know pitchers really control the
game you know it's in baseball it's not
like the Cubs against the Yankees
you know it's the pitcher the Cubs on
that day versus the Yankees batters and
vice-versa the Yankees pitcher against
the Cubs batters but there was a pitcher
for the Cubs years ago Greg Maddux and
he was great pitcher for the Cubs he
eventually left and joined Atlanta where
he's you know he prospered remember for
the Cubs he won like you know like 19 21
games or something and for the Cubs
winning 21 games is winning like 30
actually but what he did you know one of
the reasons why he was so successful is
because he hid his pitches in the sense
that you know he knows that he's gonna
see a batter probably later in the year
right if you're playing on a good team
you know you're gonna be in the playoffs
and you know you don't want to give any
advantage to a player so what he would
do is you know late in a game when game
probably didn't matter earlier in the
season is here just throw one up for the
batter to hit right because his thought
process was well I know I'm a good
pitcher I'm gonna throw this ball now so
the guy when I faced him in a critical
game right maybe not this year you know
maybe you know could be six months later
this year or it could be next year you
know that player that batter is gonna be
thinking back to when he faced me and
when he got a sweet ball to hit but what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna trick him so
the pitcher he's hiding his
aggressiveness in that sense he knows
he's got the stuff that he could get
this guy out with but rather than you
know show it all at once he's he's
hiding it so what do you think is
stronger showing all your aggressiveness
at once or hiding it you know personally
I think hiding your aggressiveness as a
traitor is more important
there's times when a big trader and me
you know doesn't really care just wants
to if he shows that he shows it if not
okay but you know over time you got to
be hiding your size that's why all these
algos execution algos exists now so big
traders can hide what they're doing in
the market so here's a piece of advice
all right bars with multiple imbalances
often occur before bars with stacked
imbalances appear bars with multiple
imbalances often occur in early stages
of moves so here's a chart with multiple
imbalances at the start of a trend right
here you're at your little of the day
right in here all right after this is e
minis this is a one-minute chart right
8:45 coming into the lows you know 846
847 and then BOOM the aggressive buying
appears one two three imbalances in the
bar next bar follows up with another
three imbalances here you have two
imbalances all right here you got two
imbalances now my software you could
decide you know whether you want to see
two or three or four I think this one I
have set the two but again that's up to
you to decide now then this presentation
is not about selling you my software I'm
talking about you know imbalances and
market exhaustion but I know many of you
guys have my software so I just want to
explain that out real quick now do you
see any stack buying imbalances no you
know if you're just sitting back waiting
for stacked buying imbalances to buy or
sell well you don't have any but you're
at your low of the day and all of a
sudden you're seeing aggressive buying
come in alright that's important
information okay there you go right you
get the little push-up bars with stacked
mine and balances okay then you hit this
swing high all of a sudden the
aggressive selling comes in one two
three bars you got three bars up step
buying imbalances then also you got
three bars Donal stacked selling it
balances well you think this markets
going higher no the Mayan balances are
no longer there just as you know you got
these little bars in here with you know
to sell and balances to sell and
imbalances okay maybe start selling off
but then you see the aggressive buying
just comes right back up continues in
the next bar into the next
but then it stops right if aggressive
buying stops what do you think is gonna
happen
mark is gonna go up it's gonna go down
well it's gonna go down if there's no
more aggressive buying so what you like
to see it's multiple bars with multiple
selling imbalances and around the high
the day which often precedes a sell-off
just as you'd like to see
yeah at the low of the day multiple bars
with multiple buying imbalances at or
around the low of the day which often
proceeds a rally and again this is a
great example right mini Dow or at our
high of the day you got stacks selling
about multiple selling balances you got
this bar one two three four
selling it balances market makes a new
high by a tick not the end of the world
then you got another bar with three
selling balances and other bar with
three selling imbalances then look that
market just drops drops you know 60
ticks in this is a minute chart you got
your big stack selling imbalance in here
great but you want to be alerted before
you get that big bar down with a big
stack selling a balance in it right
where would you rather be short from you
know up up here at 28 8 20 or short from
you know 28 790 well you wanna be short
from up there of course right so you
want the signs coming in as early as
possible and again you know if you're
looking at a normal bar or candlestick
chart you don't see any of that
information this is that same footprint
chart here on a bar chart you don't see
this tax on accounts you don't see at
this high of the day you don't see
multiple selling imbalances you don't
see as the market rallies back up makes
a new high by a tick comes back up
circles back up towards that high starts
coming off you don't see the aggressive
selling in these red bars you just see
red bars people say well you got red
bars that's bearish well okay you know
we were bearish here we were bearish
here then you know a double doji old
people double doji gotta trade that okay
fine
but just cuz you got red bars doesn't
necessarily mean you have aggressive
sellers in control of the bar just means
the bar closed lower than where it
opened what you're looking for is the
aggressive selling in the bar at prices
in the bar
and again if you're looking at a normal
bar chart this is your same bar chart
right here's your imbalances here here
here that's your normal bar chart can't
see it this is the bar here with this
blue triangle is some buying imbalances
you're the red triangle down is your
multiple selling imbalances right it
wouldn't be nice to have a tool that
highlighted to you where there are bars
with multiple buying or selling
imbalances so let me ask you you know if
you're looking at this chart can you
spot the aggressive selling no you can't
you just be guessing but this is where
it occurs right it's right here that's
these blue areas here you can see these
are the aggressiveness with multiple
buying imbalances in the red areas are
the multiple selling imbalances alright
people say well you know these two the
buying imbalances that didn't work well
okay fine you know you've got one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven times that did occur little two
didn't work but look at that you've got
you know eight nine that worked nicely
so you know that sort of wraps up the
part on imbalances that I want to talk
about because the next part I want to
talk about is market exhaustion all
right and eventually I'm gonna tie them
both together to show you how you can
take advantage of it in the market so
moving on to market exhaustion this is
the second part
it occurs basically when the last buyer
has bought at the high of a move or the
last seller has sold at the low of a
move okay and what does that look like
you know it looks like a reversal
basically now the high or low can occur
in a move or can occur in a bar so again
if you're looking at a 15-minute bar
what's that made of it's made of
15-minute 1 15 one-minute bars
alright so within a 15-minute bar you
know there's gonna be swing highs and
swing lows you know if you're just
looking at a 15-minute chart bar you
don't know what it you know what
Bend right here you know we opened up
sold off rally back up sold off you know
then closed right that's what a bar a
time-based bar looks like right it
doesn't show you what's happening it
just shows you where we opened where we
closed or the high and the low was in
the bar now
market exhaustion is identified by
looking at the volume at the ends of a
bar you know if we know market
exhaustion occurs when the last buyer
has bought or sold our last buyers
bought or the last seller has sold where
do you look for you look for that market
turning points right what happens at
market turning points all the market
reverses right just as I showed you here
right imagine you get up to the high up
here and you see very little volume
being transacted at the high well that's
telling you buyers aren't interested in
great transacting at this high just as
you know on this on the red chart here
right we get down to that low and
there's very little interest selling
interest at that low well it's telling
you sellers aren't interested at that
low add a reversal high what do you need
well you need a red candle right the
price action has to show you the market
is undergoing a reversal that the market
has to have reached a high and is now
selling off at a reversal low what do
you need you need a green candle right
the price action has to show you the
market is reversing that a low has been
made and it is now rallying right and
this is where order flow comes in by
looking at a volume footprint chart you
could see the volume that goes through
at the highs are the lows right if
you're looking at a normal bar cart
you're not gonna see what the volumes
are transacting it at this high or at
this low are you just gonna see well we
had a high up here we had a low here
okay very weak volume at the high tells
you there's very little buying interest
in the market at these levels just as
very weak volume at the low tells you
very little selling interest remains in
the market you can if no one is buying
at high prices what's the market gonna
do think about it right if you're at
high prices but no one's buying anymore
Mark's not gonna go up it's gonna sell
off it's gonna drop all right if no
one's selling at low prices
where's the selling pressure it's no
longer there
markets gonna rise buying is gonna
outnumber the selling again the key is
to be able to identify this small volume
right now let me preface that by saying
some markets trade a lot more volume
than others as a result you can and
should think about how that affects the
definition of small volume for example
small volume on NASDAQ could be five
Lots or less you know on a one-minute
chart but for the e-mini
you know maybe you want to consider 25
Lots to be small volume on a one-minute
chart because the amount of volume that
gets traded you know on a 1-minute chart
in the e-mini S&P z-- is a lot more than
the volume that goes through on a
one-minute Nasdaq chart but again you
know you could keep it the same you keep
it five if you want for both for highly
liquid markets like the ten-year notes
you know maybe you're gonna consider 100
Lots small volume because each price
level is trading you know five thousand
ten thousand contracts so you know a
hundred contracts isn't very much
relatively speaking no if you're looking
at a normal bar chart you can't see the
volume that's being traded people say oh
you got this
you had the swing high here we sold off
to the swing low you rallied up you know
and you know they come up with a lot of
excuses a lot of reasons why they would
have sold here and bought here you know
we all like to look at a chart and I
would've bought here I was sold up here
you know but the reality is that's not
how it works in in real life you need a
chart that shows you the volume that's
traded alright and again my water flows
trader chart will highlight those
numbers to you so you can see here right
this green line is the high of the day
is he hit the high of the day you have
this little red box up here to Lots
traded in there you come off rally back
up towards it high
you got another red box for contracts
market sells off was telling me is at
this high of the day buying volume dried
up you know it hit it and you could see
each time you hit that high volume is
less than the last time you did it you
only got two buyers up there market
sells off makes another run up towards
the high but again so it hits this level
and can't push through it the last time
it trades that only four contracts go
through no buying interest you know
Marcus exhausted they don't want to buy
any more all right
you need a chart that's gonna highlight
that information too right here you hit
your high hey this is great you know I
got this bar guy stacked buying
imbalance
we're at the high of the day FOMO baby
FOMO was by it what happens market can't
doesn't go any higher in the next 1 2 3
4 5 6 bars we test the high again test
it again three contracts trade where's
your aggressive buyers you know earlier
you're coming in here coming up to the
high you got aggressive buying going on
the traders aren't able to take it any
higher test the high again nobody's
interested nobody's interested to buy
what do you think is gonna happen
Mark's not gonna go higher it's gonna
start going lower and you see how it
does that
now how you gonna do this right
you could look at time and sales you can
look at a dome you can look at a volume
footprint chart all right it's like
Goldilocks and the three bears
you know trying to figure out what what
you should use time and sales dome and a
footprint chart well this poor just too
hot this one's too cold this one's just
nice you know this bed is too hard this
one's too soft this one's just nice well
I prefer a volume footprint chart now
there's again there's gonna be some
people that are gonna say no you gotta
look at a dome know you got look at time
and sales you know I like to make things
easier I don't like to sit here and
stare at a dome that's going berserk Oh
on me you know especially at busy times
in the market I like to look at the
footprint chart because it gives me a
more relaxed pressureless environment to
trade in honestly and as you can see
here right this green box around the
numbers tell me there's there's a small
print here it's telling me there's
market exhaustion right there's only six
contracts traded here at the low come
back up we start testing a little only
four contracts trade here we started
rallying again market puts in and you
know at the low of this bar where you
have the multiple binding balances you
that mark is Austin at the bottom you
know no one's interested in selling here
people are interested in buying you know
these are all clues that you can use
in your trading right and again remember
there's safety in numbers right primal
animal instinct right safety and numbers
stay together right well the lion what
he's looking for is the weak one
all right he's looking for the one
that's straggling off on the side here
right that's his easy prey you know
either the old guy or you know the one
that's injured or the one that's just
you know daydreaming on the side not
paying attention that's where he's gonna
get his dinner and training is the same
way you picking off these areas on the
chart right these are the stragglers so
to speak you know that you know there's
no interest there all right if you're
alert to those levels that you know
don't expect the market to come back to
those right away so this is an e mini
5-minute chart okay and as you can see
on these extremes nothing it's just your
normal order flow but up here look at
this on this red bar right off the high
when you got five Lots right traders
aren't interested in buying this area up
in here market cells off cells off cells
off cells off you know from 72 down to
62 starts going sideways then you get
down here or Lots right that you know
towards the right side here you can see
for last trade on the bottom of this
green bar just going sideways a little
bit higher a higher low another four
Lots market starts creeping back up so
prices are being rejected down here down
around this the 62 and a half 60 to 61
and 3/4 area just as up here earlier
traders are now rejecting this 3373 area
call these small prints right again
right off the high hit yeah you're
making new high make a new high in each
bars five-minute crude chart well the
next bar opens up makes a run at that
high but just got no more steam left you
know traders are
exhausted from buying these highs
thinking we're going higher market sells
off gets down to the swing low starts
ticking up again nine right it's a small
print there one you know just goes
sideways another five minute chart right
would market is you know in a range here
basically pops up a little bit but
traitors aren't interested or lots what
happens market closes down then boom
falls over so you get down here you get
down to this level around the you know
seventy to seventy-five area start
reeling up as you do
traders are rejecting these areas down
here around seventy-five again here's a
chart it's a ten-year chart I mean look
at the volume that's going through on
ten years at a price level on nine
thousand versus twelve thousand at at
the same level you know in in the
diagonal you got like up a period four
thousand versus five thousand four
thousand seven hundred verses five
thousand seven hundred but look at that
you got three you hit your high start
coming off start to rally back up yeah
the real atch transacted up here on a
market that trades how many thousands at
a price level you know just says you
have four over here right before the
market rallied up again you got
thousands being traded at a price level
one come on you know this is you know
traders like to make things more
complicated than not just look at the
volume that's going through if it's
light the Sun your traitors aren't
interested in those areas you know
imagine what's going on you hit your
high come off start rallying going back
up towards your high but you put in
three contracts only man this mark
is getting ready to sell off again if it
doesn't sell off well what's your risk
you know your risk is you know a couple
ticks here it's not like you're risking
you know the bank or anything like that
you know you had a very low risk trade
if you see this three Lots going through
and you don't
realize that you know that that's
important in the sense that no traders
aren't interested in buying anymore you
missing a great trading opportunity it's
a five minute euro currency chart I mean
look at this you got your swing high
here
you hit your low rattly up you hit it
mark bar closes next bar opens up but
only where's the follow-through right on
minute base charts especially you always
want to be looking for follow-through in
the next bar and you're not seeing it
here all right you just see three
contracts traded you know you know
previous bar trait hundred and fourteen
at that level next bar just three it
immediately comes off alright and then
sells off sells off making down new lows
at the low of the day what do you got
you got one contract traded at the low
the day before the amount market bounces
back up from you know the 35 area up to
the 42 area so hopefully by now you
understand and see the importance of
small prints now I'm not advocating that
you just automatically fade small prints
whenever one appears right what I do is
I look for areas where small prints and
imbalances occur together combined with
a few other factors of order flow but
that's my starting point you know small
prints and imbalances I can get into
some of the other details but you know I
want you to grasp the importance of
small prints and imbalances together all
right because a footprint chart gives
you the information but you need to know
what to look for and put it all together
so if you're looking at this chart right
this is an e mini eight range chart okay
even the eight range chart trades
thousands you know anywhere between five
to fifteen thousand lots in a bar so you
know if you're sticking with you know
small print of you know five or or ten
yeah you can honestly I like to use a
little higher threshold I use 25 on very
thick markets like a minis so we're
gonna get you know where's your trade
it's right here this bar if you're
looking at again a train chart
where's the market exhaustion I
hopefully you know you start to see it
over time but it's right here
use your long here's your short right
you've got again I told you I'm using
threshold of 22 sorry 25 this is 22 here
this is 19 I've got multiple cell and
imbalances in this bar I've got multiple
buying imbalances in this bar where's
the market exhaustion I know some people
going to say well you got it right here
you got it here but it actually occurs
earlier here's here first time now again
I told you there's there's few there's
other things that go into how I
determined but that's my starting point
okay so I've got my 25 threshold here's
is 16 falls within it I got my multiple
imbalances in here and I stacked and
balanced actually again if you're just
using you know pure small print and
multiple imbalances you know you've got
one here you've got one here you've got
one here again if you're using two
imbalances you've got another one here
so imagine that you're knowing you've
got 1 2 3 4 bars in a row but you want
to get in as early as possible so for
the untrained eye of the trader it's
gonna be difficult to see so how to make
it easy well I have a tool for that it's
called the market exhaustion tool for a
ninja trader it runs on ninjatrader 8
it's going to allow you to see areas
where price is being rejected in real
time by traders now again if you're
looking at a normal foot print chart
where you gonna see it you gotta pick it
up and you gotta know what you're
looking for right you guys see well yeah
I've got my imbalances I've got my small
print
and you know like I said there's a few
other nuts and bolts that go into it but
if you're looking at it you know
sometimes you're looking at so much
information on a chart that you just get
overwhelmed right it's better just have
a tool that's gonna highlight it to you
right like right here and you know where
is it here you know where would you want
to be short from oh right here this is
your bar you know might start selling
off circles back a little bit before it
puts in a big move lower okay
date range chart key minis where is it
it's right here
crude oil eight range chart where is it
it's right here so if you're interested
in this indicator it's just strategy
fifty dollars and it comes with a
ninety-eight page user guide and
settings and right now I could go over a
lot of settings with you which is
important because you know different
markets I think have different settings
I also have an additional one hour and
36 minute training video so if you
interested go to market exhaustion calm
now
I've showed you how to spot market
exhaustion on a volume footprint chart
especially using the market exhaustion
tool from my website order flows but
what if you don't use a volume footprint
chart what if you're just using a normal
candlestick chart you know most people
haven't made that transition to using
order file yet in the sense of looking
at a volume footprint chart you know
they're still using a normal bar chart
candlestick chart if you're looking at
this chart you're just guessing all this
market exhaustion here or you know there
etc well if you're using the tool you
can see these mark exhaustion here here
this one failed here's one here there's
one here there's one little group here
that failed then you got another market
exhaustion here and market exhaustion
here crude oil one-minute chart that's
what it looks like it took off I've took
in this chart I've taken off these
bars that go across just so it's a
little easier to see and you know the
beauty of it is you know it plots it on
there so if you're using a tool like
markers from the indicator store you
know you can you can hook it up hook it
up but you can set it up in there too
you know basically trade for you when
you're not at your desk it's crude one
minute chart
boom boom boom sell sell sell right
here's the settings that I'm using
sensitivity of five okay a swing filter
I told you there's some other things
that go into it but you can see the
sensitivity is the small print the
imbalance triggers I've got you know
whether it's looking we're gonna take
into some of the other bars no previous
bars into a count or not you can turn it
on and turn it off minimum volume
required whether you want Delta
confirmation or the prominent point of
control confirmation
here's euro currency one-minute chart
again previous chart was a crude oil
one-minute chart this is a euro currency
one-minute chart here's a cell just sort
of went down a little bit on sideways
and then boom you got the nice big cell
here you got a by here just kind of went
sideways you know unfortunately you know
it's not all gonna be you know the big
massive move that you want sometimes
you're gonna get trades were you know it
starts out working then just go sideways
on you right that's what's called trade
management again settings are the same
alright same settings right I'm using
five one five checkmark one zero four
hundred two basic settings same settings
mini Dow one-minute chart some buys sell
bunch of buys you know catching this
entire move up here this one you know
its mini Dow it's a lot thinner than
crude oil and your currency so I've
adjusted sensitivity down a little bit
to two and imbalances I'm just looking
for one again you could set these up to
whatever you want to use Nasdaq
one-minute chart same thing but you know
buys in here so by right here right
around the cash open which probably
would stop you out then starts coming
back up you know and it makes a move
here from you know ninety three ninety
to ninety area i'll hip to ninety
three thirties in here you know doesn't
look like a big move but it's Nasdaq and
it you know trust me it's a that's a big
movies because the way this market has
been recently you're getting big moves
right so you want to catch those and
this one because again you can adjust
the sensitivity I got a set to zero okay
which basically I'm just looking for
multiple imbalances in a bar you know
402 a e-mini for range chart okay you
know people say well you got this bar
here that didn't work well you got one
two three four trades three worked one
didn't okay fine
you know not all trades are gonna be
winners but you know I want you to show
that I could just show you a bunch of
charts were you know it's all picture
perfect right it's gotta be times where
you get that because for whatever reason
right after you get into a trade mark
doesn't move just cuz you bought it all
the other traders also have to be going
in the same direction and with order
flow you understand what's happening in
the market what the other traders are
doing you know when they're being
aggressive and whatnot settings still
relatively the same you know I'm using
three swing period of to 402 crude oil
for range chart
sell sell buy buy sell sell sell sell
sell I don't need to explain that again
you know sensitivity is three relatively
the same on everything else they'll
again I'm just showing you this was
earlier this was the e-mini right same
settings on the four range a mini chart
I'm using on the crude oil for range
chart so how else can you use this well
what about markets that move fast and
have lots of volatility and and be
honest you know these markets nowadays
have a lot of volatility and they move
very fast well why don't you just start
by looking for bars with lots of
imbalances right and you know how you're
gonna set it up sensitivity you can make
it a little bit higher well bars with
you know six imbalances well would you
consider six imbalances a lot yes and
this is what it looks like this is a
Nasdaq one-minute chart
this sells pies you know sells and again
it you know again not every trade is
gonna be a winner this one is just
purely looking for bars with six
imbalances in them and what was the
other studying you know so you can see
do you think that's important do you
think just imbalances by themselves are
important well yeah they are you can see
here obviously Mars with six balances is
a lot okay well how about crude oil five
imbalances in the bar look at this it's
a one minute chart right same settings
well this time a the sense it's gonna be
a bit higher to fifty because obviously
crude oil trades a lot more volume in a
bar than Nasdaq and you see imbalances
five look at and imagine if you're
trading on a dome and you're alerted to
this as soon as it happens and you just
if you're just a scalper you know
scalping you know ticks here ticks there
and you had a tool it's gonna give you
the immediate near-term direction of
where the market is going that could
come in very handy right it's all nice
well I'm good to catch big moves yeah we
all like to catch that but the reality
is many traders sell themselves short
right they like to look at a dome
because they think they're they're
lowering the risk because they're not in
a trade longer well you need something
to tell you what the mark is doing in
the next few ticks and trust me when you
got multiple imbalances in a bar usually
very highly often the next bar continues
that direction generally it will
continue that direction over the near
term but at least in the next bar or two
it continues it with a very high
expectancy so again you know if you're
interested in this indicator it's three
to fifty dollars go to market exhaustion
calm it's not on my order flow site you
know I got a separate site for it market
exhaustion calm and again you know it
comes with additional training it's got
a ninety eight page user guide I talk
about a lot of the settings in there and
I show you in the user guy
you know different settings for
different markets and I explained them
you know again settings I use it's not
set in stone that's what it has to be
you take those settings and you develop
them into your own trading method right
and you work it in there alright because
again not all markets are put in the
same volume alright not you know the
volume that goes through on the e-mini
chart is it's much different than the
volume that goes through on a gold chart
alright the volume that goes through on
a Nasdaq chart is much different than
the volume that goes through on a
10-year chart so you know I think this
tool helps a lot of people understand
you know when you have market exhaustion
when you have aggressive activity in the
market and you know it's a great tool to
add to your trading arsenal so thanks
for watching this presentation and you
know happy trading
enjoy